this came as senate republicans
officially released
their version of a coronavirus stimulus
plan
while it includes a second round of
twelve hundred dollar payments
it would only extend additional
unemployment payments by
two hundred dollars a week through
september
that's compared to the current payment
of 600 dollars
starting in october a worker's lost
wages would be covered up to 70 percent
joining us now from capitol hill is new
york senator and democratic minority
leader chuck schumer
senator good morning negotiations with
negotiations with the white house
started last night
u and house speaker nancy pelosi were
there
where do we stand right now well
unfortunately we're pretty far apart
right now although i'm optimistic we
could have a good
solution at the end here's where we are
now we democrats have put together a
package that is bold and strong
and deals with the average needs of
people we don't let them get kicked out
of their homes because they've lost
their job through no fault to their own
we give them a good amount of
unemployment insurance so they can pay
we put in money to feed kids we put in
money to open schools
safely people want schools open but it
has to be done
safely and we give money to state and
local governments because
thousands hundreds of thousands of
firefighters and bus drivers and garbage
workers will be laid off
the republican plan does almost none of
these things
it is stingy it doesn't provide any
money
for instance for more food for people
who need to feed their kids
it provides their unemployment insurance
you're telling people who lost their
jobs through no fault of their own they
get a 30 percent pay cut
it does nothing for state and local
governments is woefully inadequate in
helping our schools open
instead anthony amazingly it has all
these corporate benefits
no money for food stamps but a deduction
for a three martini lunch for a big
businessman
big cushion for defense contractors no
cushion for people who'd be kicked out
of their house and to boot
they threw in there president trump
wants the fbi headquarters built near
his hotel so no new competing hotel
could come in
two billion dollars for that so the
bottom line is and one more point
half the republicans of the senate even
think that's too generous
so we're pretty far apart and the
negotiations were disappointing
yeah so senator i mean the supplemental
benefit uh
unemployment benefit has already run out
for a lot of people it's due to run out
for a lot more by the end of the week um
so
if you're this far apart what are the
what's the real hope here of getting a
deal
so these people aren't in a panic as our
david begna reported from florida
even if if you did the republican plan
most states said unemployment benefits
would be cut off anyway because it's a
whole new plan and they have to readjust
their computers hire new people
many states say it would take months
before people would get their checks
there's a simple solution
the house has passed and we sent it
democrat support simply extending the
existing six hundred dollars a month
until january that could go into effect
easy
that can help our economy because it
puts monies money's money in people's
pockets and then they buy things and go
to the stores that's the only thing
that's kept the economy going
and we can get it done but senator we
urge we urge our republican colleagues
you know in the last two bills
the last two covet bills they were very
stingy we democrats said it had to be
better
and they came in our direction i'm
hopeful that will happen again
the republican argument senator as you
know is that the 600
supplemental is essentially not an
incentive for people to go back to work
it's actually keeping them from going
back to work
that misreads the american people people
want jobs they want permanent jobs they
don't want to stay on unemployment
and the evidence of how many people
doing that is very very small what's
really happening
is that they want to favor the big
corporate interests as opposed
to the average person who needs this
money
and every economist has said the
unemployment insurance has done more to
prevent us
prevent the recession from getting
greater than now why
cut it and instead put the money into
these corporate things i don't get it
the white house says that if you can't
reach an agreement you should
you should pass a narrower bill would
you support that
well you're going to choose we should
help the unemployed but not
help people be kicked out of their homes
not help feed people
not help schools open there are so many
needs remember
this is the greatest economic crisis
we've had since the great depression
this is the greatest health crisis
since the spanish flu we need a bold
package we believe
that the republicans will have to move
in our direction because the public is
completely on our side
so many even republican economists are
on our side they're being held back
by a group of hard right-wing people in
the senate who don't want to spend any
money on anything and say let the people
be damned
is is eviction protection part of this
bill no
it's part of our bill but not part of
theirs people will be kicked out of
their houses starting next week
we can't let that happen so where
you're going to have to give up
something senator where do you think you
can meet the republican side
well look we're happy to sit down and
talk and roll up our sleeves and try we
sat down with mnuchin and with um
meadows last night and there has to be
some kind of
of you know there has to be some kind of
meeting but you cannot forego the
desperate needs of people because
there's a small band
of hard right republicans saying don't
do anything as i said
the last three bills the republicans
started out very narrow
we democrats held our ground and said
there are a lot of needs and they moved
in our direction
i'm very hopeful that will happen again
and will be able to meet these needs
so your both bills prioritize schools
but you're offering significantly more
money not only more money
we offer money to d schools have real
problems in opening up
if you give every kid a mask and every
teacher a mask that's hundreds of
thousands of dollars you probably have
to have two bus routes if the kids are
sitting in a bus right next to each
other you can only have one seat
double the bus routes a lot of schools
want to convert their gyms
their cafeterias to classrooms you need
some help with distance learning for
people who don't have adequate wi-fi
there's a lot to be done and we provide
for it this is a huge crisis
and if we are too stingy it's going to
get worse that's what the president's
actions have shown
thus far we're trying to overcome it
the clock is ticking here can you reach
a deal by the end of the
next week i hope so and that's what
we're working for we'll sit down we're
going to sit down again today we'll sit
down 24
7. people's needs are so great that we
will do whatever we can to reach a deal
but without foregoing their basic needs
senator schumer thank you very much for
being with us thank you
good to talk to you anthony